des caméras cachées et s'est fait passé
pour un chanteur dépressif en fait il
était un gros gros gros concert il est
même monté sur scène avec une chanson
pas si vous avez vu une chanson de
dépressif
c'est énorme regardez ce qu'il a fait et
jean-luc je voudrais encore vous
remercier parce que c'était encore
énorme les 4-7 c'est greg guillotin avec
mon pote au mail on a fait une caméra
cachée où je me suis fait passer pour le
chanteur le plus dépressif au monde au
regard tout de suite
vous et moi de vous déranger avec mon
ami en fait on doit présenter les
chansons d'un festival et on aimerait
bien avoir un avis ou pour faire un
petit extrait rapidement je perds mon
poêle jeu vaut que dal
je suis une merde
sans conteste je ramasse mairesse
[Musique]
alors c'est
wells pas très joyeux me mettrais bien
une ou deux balles dans le pied
jouer tout frais avec un oreiller l'agly
non c'est un peu triste au moins deux
tristes on suit les rondelles
à qui on a coupé les ailes je suis le
rouge murphy ségo je suis le pivert
qu'on enterre qu'est-ce qui est là c'est
juste un extrait qu'on vous fait
c'est que les paroles sont très très je
vous le dis aujourd'hui je voudrais
tirer la chasse d'eau de magrie mais je
me sentirais plus à l'aise quand je me
serai chuté de la falaise
je pète pas très 2
c'est triste on peut faire le rapport de
pearl harbor civeyrac
mais très bien eu deux balles dans le
pied
je mets tout frais avec un oreiller
ça vous a plu
c'est plutôt trop triste on peut le
dégoût de la vie s'échappe
drôle qui portent plus vers la lumière
vous croyez que je suis heureux mais
fait qu'une façade
vous vous rendrez compte encore je vais
crever ça vous plaît
et je sors d'un de mes lectures très
positive pour cet été l'idée c'est de
dire voilà la vie vaut pas la peine
d'être vécue
[Musique]
bravo pour la création artistique
je garde la mort
dans le viseur
les nazis j'ai même erreur
je me sens d'abord je suis le rat mort
le pearl harbor pourquoi
là vous allez les mecs et greg ont testé
leur amour de pearl harbor
nous on n'a pas l'habitude d'avoir des
rires pas ce genre de chanson mais c'est
vrai que la mini le dernier je pense à
l'autre
[Applaudissements]